hi
i'm greg braille from google i want to
talk today about apis
in particular about how companies are
using apis to deliver new experiences
for their customers
whether those are business customers or
ordinary people
and how you can actually do that in your
business
there are going to be three parts to
this talk we're going to start with an
update
about some ways in which people are
using apis today
some ways in which companies are using
apis to deliver new digital experiences
and in some cases even new business to
business experiences
we're also going to talk about how you
can govern and manage those apis through
the whole life cycle
so any apis you create can actually be
useful
and productive and allow all sorts of
new technologies to be created
and finally i want to talk about
implementation strategies what is api
management
how does it fit in how do you actually
fit an api or an api
program into today's kind of digital
architecture
first however we want to talk a little
bit about what's important on our mind
today and some of the things that we're
thinking about a lot
in today's world first of all we're
thinking a lot about health care
we're thinking about being healthy we're
thinking about keeping our families
healthy
we're thinking about how we're gonna get
health care how are we going to visit
the doctor
are we going to do a video visit of our
actual visit
how are we going to pay for the doctor
what's the status of our insurance
these are all the kinds of things that
are on our mind today
we're also going to talk about food we
all have to eat
and nowadays we find ourselves asking
questions like
where's dinner coming from are we going
to cook it are we getting grocery
delivery
are we going to the grocery store are we
ordering our food
are we calling on a phone are we using
an app are we using a delivery service
there are more options than there have
ever been before and a lot of those
options are driven by apis
and finally we want to talk about how we
get the things we need to run our
household
how do we get those necessities of daily
life where are we going to find them are
there enough in the store
can we order them online do we need to
have them delivered
do we need to go to the store and get
them these are all the kinds of
questions that people are asking
retail is one of those industries that's
been going through a digital
transformation for a long time now
and apis are an important part of what
they do as well
so let me talk about three companies who
are actually in these three particular
areas
and some innovative things that they're
doing with apis
the first company is change health care
change health care is not a health care
provider or a hospital conglomerate or a
doctor
they're a service provider to all those
people in particular they offer
something that they call the api and
services connection for healthcare
which is just what it sounds like it's a
set of apis
that these different kinds of healthcare
providers can use
in order to deliver things like health
eligibility calculations
patients responsibility calculations so
when you're going to go to the doctor
you can have some idea
how much you'll have to pay out of
pocket versus how much insurance will
cover
so basically they're a service provider
for all these health care companies that
want to offer a better digital patient
experience
and they're using apis for you know one
of the things that we've talked about
apis being useful for for many years
which is to allow third-party innovation
they provide a set of services
and their customers can then build on
those services to deliver innovative
technology for all of their consumers
now if we move on to food one company
that's no stranger to a digital
experience is pizza hut
pizza hut now has an app called the
pizza tracker and the pizza tracker
literally lets you keep track of your
pizza and believe it or not
on the super bowl which is the american
football championship which is a big
event in america
a lot of people want pizza and when they
order that pizza they want to know where
it is so pizza hut has to not only
deliver these new digital experiences
because people don't just want to call
the local pizza place and have someone
mumble back to them and
hope that their pizza is going to arrive
in time for the kickoff
they want to know that they're going to
get the exact pizza they ordered when
they ordered it
when they need it so for that this pizza
tracker is a new digital experience
they've created
and they've built it on top of a layer
of apis
that connects to systems that they
already had within the business for
tracking these things
in addition of course they have to deal
with these huge traffic spikes the super
bowl is the probably the biggest one
they've had to deal with to date
so they take advantage of all the things
underneath the api layer like auto
scaling
google kubernetes engine and other
technologies like that
so that when that demand spikes their
i.t systems don't struggle
and you don't give the customers a bad
experience instead you give them a good
experience
of giving them a responsive app that
lets them track that very important
thing
that's on their way to their house to
keep their friends happy and fit
and finally we'll talk about retail
retail's been doing digital things for a
long time
um but there are a lot of new things
that are happening conrad electronic is
one example they're actually in germany
and one of the things they did
is they took a lot of the data from
their existing legacy data warehouse and
moved it into bigquery
this is not a big query presentation
there are some great ones at
next i'm sure you can listen to but one
of the things they did with bigquery
then
was give access to those data warehouse
items
via an api by doing that now their b2b
customers can now use those apis on top
of bigquery
to have more timely and more accurate
information about conrad's offerings and
even their inventory
than they could have before because they
gave them a channel
for getting that information that's much
easier for developers to consume
in addition and we'll talk a little bit
about this pattern as well
once they had those apis they could
build a new in-store tool
and that in-store tool is something that
their associates in the store can use
in order to help customers better
understand what's in stock
what the price is and now when you come
to the store the people who work in the
store with that tool are better informed
than they ever were before resulting in
a better customer experience which i
imagine means
you know more people want to shop there
so that's a really cool example of using
an api for multiple contexts
both for b2b as well as to improve the
way things work internally
and improve their own customer
experience
so that's a little bit about how apis
are being used by all kinds of companies
and they all have apis at the core
really
and what we found is that you know i've
been talking about apis on and off since
about 2009
it began as something that people you
know were not sure
why we were talking about it like really
do we really want to offer these
external services
and now they've really become the way
that industries of all types communicate
and those examples are just some of the
examples
of the way that people are doing things
like building new mobile applications
building other kind of digital
applications and building
business-to-business services
based on apis but of course once you
build the api
you have to govern it you have to keep
track of it and you have to make that
api useful
and that's really where a lot of the
challenge of api management comes in
whenever we talk about apis at google we
almost always start with this little
chart you see here
which we call the digital value chain
and there are a couple of important
things about this one important thing
is of course it mentions the technology
after all an api
is a bit of technology that sits in
between a back end and an app
it's literally the connection between
the app and the back end
but an equally important part of this
value chain maybe even more important
is the connection between the people and
the connection that we're especially
interested in when we talk about apis
is that connection between the developer
who uses the api
and the api team or the people who
create the api
or manage or govern or even are
sometimes called the product managers of
the api
because making an api successful is more
than just sticking something on the
internet with an endpoint
and telling people to use it it includes
all kinds of
of aspects that a product manager has to
consider when they want to make their
api be useful
the interesting thing about this digital
value chain it also lets us focus
on sort of you know where the real value
is
so as technologists we always want to
start with the back end stuff
stuff we understand we have a legacy
system that
keeps track of our inventory for us
let's expose it as an api
okay what does the api look like well it
looks like our back-end system how do
you use it
i don't know do you know our back-end
system that's how you use it
that's not a really always the best way
to make some technology useful outside
the organization
but it's often where we start but it's
not always the most effective way what
about the developers
how are they going to use those apis
effectively what about the actual
customer
does the api do what they need so it
makes sense in another perspective often
to talk about an outside-in perspective
starting with really what do the
customers want um if it's a
business-to-consumer aspect
you have product managers you have
people in the organization
who probably have all sorts of great
ideas for new services they could offer
to their customers
going back to that pizza hut pizza
tracker app someone within pizza hut had
an idea to build that app
they had to come to a technology team
and say how are we going to build that
where's the information we need to build
that
well it may be locked inside legacy
systems in your company
and it may require some new apis to
expose it
as another example you might want to do
business to business like conrad did
you might want to actually make apis
that your large partners
can use to have a more efficient
relationship with you which
we hope would drive more business that
might drive a different kind of api
there might not only be a different set
of requirements for what the api does
but there could be different
requirements for the technology maybe
security has to work differently
maybe the data's got to be presented in
a different format
these are all questions that a really
effective api team
probably ought to be asking when they
start to do something with apis
so a great example of how to apply this
digital value chain
is to start with a real actionable
project and then move on
in order we did a webinar recently with
mtn
which is a multinational telco located
in africa and they've embraced apis and
i think they have a great example
for how you can actually use this
digital value chain in production
they started by solving the problem
right in front of them they needed some
specific point-to-point apps
and they created apis to support those
apps
but then they learned that they could
use those same apis for other things for
some of their web apps
to drive their call centers and then
after that they were able to have
additional
pieces of functionality that they could
build with their apis
like omnichannel retail like apis for
use by their partners
even eventually things like digital
assistance and iot
devices all of these things began to be
possible
as they started with a simple api and
started by solving a single business
problem
and then they branched out to build a
much more comprehensive platform
where today they have a wide variety of
apis and a wide variety of business
processes and this has really enabled
them to speed up
the ways in which their customers and
their own product managers can create
new things
and we've seen this example across a
whole lot of industries where
you know companies that used to you know
take months to
bring a new partner on board or create a
new marketing campaign
are able to do this sort of thing in
days or weeks because once you have the
api
and once you have the technology to make
it possible for people to consume it via
self-service
the cost to get a new consumer on that
api is extremely low
before you had apis and before you had
self-service it was a totally different
world
when you have to build a completely new
service or a new business or hire
software developers
in order to implement a new idea it's
much much much more expensive
than when someone can simply sign up for
an api via self-service using an
interface that a developer understands
well
and start working on it so what we find
is that the customers that succeed with
apis
end up sort of moving up this chain from
the left to the right
people often start out with apis to
solve point-to-point problems and that's
fine
we need to integrate system a and system
b let's do it with an api
so maybe once that integration is built
we can use it in other ways
or we need to build a a new mobile
application
let's build an api for that mobile
application but let's make it reusable
enough
that we'll be able to use it for other
applications in the future
and that's where we start to move up to
the right we move from basically giving
access to apis
to creating those differential digital
experiences like the pizza hut pizza
tracker
but where the real interesting stuff
comes is when people are able to use
those apis to create ecosystems
to create new types of business and to
enter in
new ways for people to interact with
them with them
as companies so there are a couple of
different reasons
why you might want to have an ecosystem
one is simply you may be able to unlock
new lines of business
um i mean going back i'm not sure
exactly what lines of business pizza hut
did but if i look for instance at
what we talked about with change
healthcare right they created a whole
new business
around offering api related services
for healthcare providers to use
those ecosystems also help you better
meet the needs of the customers and
that's a really important thing and they
help you discover new customers
those are really important because once
you've started to use an api to build an
ecosystem
you may find that some of the best
customer experiences
and some of the best new lines of
business for you could come
from people who are using your apis from
outside your company
we've talked for years about apis some
being something that you use to drive
third-party innovation and that remains
true
and we have a number of customers who
are doing that and doing that in some
very interesting ways
one great example of this area is
ticketmaster ticketmaster
is primarily u.s but i know they have an
international presence
and they're very successful at selling
tickets to online events
well real events now maybe at this
particular moment there aren't as many
of those selling as there once were
but that will come back and what
ticketmaster did is they've created an
api
and this has now enabled places like
retailers like costco
digital platforms like facebook you
could even imagine an airline or a hotel
company
saying hey when you book tickets at our
hotel you might also want to get tickets
to our local play using ticketmaster
and because they have those apis for
business-to-business interaction
they're actually able to create whole
new business channels
to enable them to be embedded in someone
else's digital experience
and a great example of that is that in
2018
15 of their ticket sales were coming
this way
so they've really seen that by creating
those apis and creating a platform or an
ecosystem
now third parties can do innovative
things with the services
that they already offer now a key to
making all this work
is what we call an api product which is
basically to say that
these apis are not just technology an
api is not simply a list
of urls and verbs and oauth tokens and
tls requirements and rate limits and
json that's the technology behind the
api
but when you build an api you're
creating it for somebody
you're creating it for a developer who's
going to build an app
so you have to think about all the
different aspects of that how are you
going to secure that
so that the right security mechanism is
used that for one your developers can
actually understand
but that meets the security requirements
for the kind of data that's in your api
you've got to think about how you're
going to monitor and analyze it so you
can tell
whether people are using that api
effectively whether it's bringing
business value
whether developers are being successful
you might even think about monetizing
your api which is you might find cases
where it makes sense to charge for an
api
that's not something that often comes up
but there are a number of companies who
have apis
that provide businesses where literally
on a transactional basis they're worth a
lot of money they provide
very detailed financial projections for
instance that's a great example for
monetizing an api directly
we find other cases like ticketmaster
where it may actually not make sense to
monetize your api because it's driving
more business to you
or you might even want to pursue a
profit sharing philosophy
where people who are using your api to
drive business to you might actually
take a share of your profits
we've seen people do all these kinds of
things with apis but the key to it
is to enable self-service for developers
that's really what apis and api
management are all about
it's not that difficult to put the
technology in place
to make it possible to call something in
your business over http
send it some json and get a result back
but now if you want
tens or hundreds or hundreds of
thousands of developers to use that api
either inside your company or outside
your company you've really got to think
about how they're going to learn about
it
how they're going to get access to it
and how they can do this via
self-service
if using your api requires going to a
meeting or attending a conference call
it's a lot less interesting than if it's
something you can do right there in your
web browser on your computer
okay now we talked about some examples
of using apis
we talked a little bit about apis as
products and the importance of
self-service
let's talk about how we do this and how
apis and api management
actually fit in an organization so
within an organization apis can be
everywhere
they can be in legacy systems they can
come from sas vendors they can be
third-party apis increasingly we see
more and more
people having third-party services
coming over the internet that are part
of the apis they're delivering even
inside a corporate network or internal
applications
of course we have vms we have legacy
systems we have serverless platforms we
have kubernetes
we have all kinds of technology but one
thing that's becoming increasingly clear
in all sizes of organizations all those
bits of technology
can be used to deliver apis and apis can
sit on all of them
and they can talk to each other and
clients can talk to them and all kinds
of things can happen
and the more and more apis an
organization has
the more important it is they can be
able to keep track of them to have some
sort of governance over them
so that a product manager or even a
security person can ask
questions like what apis do we have
how effectively are they being reused
are they secured in the appropriate way
um which ones are the most popular how
many apis do we have that nobody is
using
these are the kinds of things that
people bring an api management platform
infor
because by registering apis with the api
management platform
and getting statistics and analytics
from that platform
it's actually possible to answer some of
these questions and many organizations
find out they have apis they didn't know
about
or they have apis that they do know
about but aren't being used effectively
and this is a big important step for
customers and companies that are using
apis internally
to drive all sorts of innovation of
course once we start to drive the apis
outside the organization it gets even
more interesting because now we not only
have to deal with what happens inside
but what happens outside adds a few new
layers of complexity
for instance the developers using the
api are not necessarily part of your
organization so you need to figure out
how you're going to secure that api for
their use
do they work with an existing identity
platform or do you create a new one just
for them
if developers are going to use an api
via self-service they might be using
some sort of developer portal
a website where they can learn about
apis and sign up for access
how do you secure that how do you
maintain identity there
how do you make sure your api
documentation is effective and your api
designs are effectively communicated
so whereas internal api management and
governance tends to be about things like
enforcing api design standards
enforcing api security standards and
keeping track of what's going on
api management outside the organization
now includes things
like how do i market the api how do i
make the api easy for developers to
consume
um how do i add additional levels of
security so for instance
in a lot of cases people who have apis
on the internet that don't require
security credentials to use like some
retail apis that let you get prices in
store locations
many of those are subject to attacks by
bots and these are not bots that are
doing a denial of service or trying to
hack your system
these are people who have signed up for
your api like legitimate users
but they're using it to scrape data for
their own competitive purposes
so for instance in the travel industry
let's try to book a hotel room at all
the hotels and see what price the
competition is offering there are a lot
of different and interesting kind of
security threats and other things that a
company has to take into consideration
when they offer apis outside the
organization
and one of the roles of an api
management system is to help you manage
those sorts of things as well
so now we're not only helping you govern
and maintain standards inside the
organization
we're also helping you effectively make
sure those apis are used
are used well and are used in a secure
way by people who are outside your
organization
and once you share apis outside an
organization
that's when all of the fun things we
talked about before like governance
and the ability to create an ecosystem
and the ability to enable third-party
innovation
really comes into play and where you can
really do some interesting things as an
organization
now if we jump back inside for one more
second i don't always like to leave this
without talking a little bit about the
role of internal services
and especially microservices there have
been a lot of cases recently where
people have
started to use apis internally and then
some of the organizations that are
getting a little bit more advanced have
been talking for the last few years
about microservices about breaking
individual bits of functionality
into many many smaller bits that are
then deployed
separately that may run on different
technology platforms
that may be programmed in different
languages but which communicate
most often using api technology using
http
and json or perhaps using something like
graphql
or grpc all of these things counts as
apis
and all of this microservices stuff is a
really important step
in the evolution of businesses to become
more agile and to do things more quickly
but you don't want to end up in a
situation where as we show here
we actually have a lot of micro services
that talk to each other
but we have a number of ones that we
outlined in red which
are actually the microservices that talk
to other microservices
and what we often find is that when an
organization is doing microservices
development at scale
a particular team really delivers an api
or a few apis and that api is made
visible to other teams
that team might choose to implement that
api on top of a java app server
or they might choose to implement a
mainframe or they might choose it to
implement with
five microservices or ten microservices
or a hundred microservices but for that
team to expose all 100 of those
microservices
as they are directly to all the other
teams in the company is a recipe for
disaster and chaos
so what we often find a pattern that
works very well is to create api facades
for those groups of microservices
expose that api to the other parts of
the organization
and then what's underneath the api can
change it might be that monolithic java
app today
and it might be 100 applications using
grpc and golang tomorrow
but the interface for that service and
that team to the rest of the
organization doesn't change
that becomes a real important principle
that companies can use
as they start to explore some of the new
and more agile ways to use apis and
microservices technology
and finally i want to talk about google
and some of our offerings
we've been working hard for a long time
to offer a wide variety of products in
the api and api management space
on one side of the slide we see apogee
apogee is the api management product
we've offered for a few years now
i've been working on apogee since 2007
and it's been part of google cloud
since 2016. we have a new product as
well called api gateway
it's a fully managed api gateway and in
its current form
it's especially well suited for turning
serverless workloads like that forest of
microservices we just saw
into coherent apis and we find that in
many cases people will really want to
take advantage of this api gateway
because it's it's small it's fast it's
easy to consume and it's fully native
and fully managed
as part of google cloud apigee has many
of those attributes but apogee is also
capable of full life cycle api
management
managing everything in your api program
from the definition of apis
to publishing on developer portals to
monetization and advanced analytics
and over time you'll see us adding more
capabilities to both of these products
in order to give it a really good set of
capabilities so that our customers with
wide varieties of api needs
can find the right solution in google
cloud
so finally thank you thank you on behalf
of everyone at google cloud for joining
me today
and may you have some really awesome
digital journeys in the future